you sweatin why people with flavoring  like that what a movie comes in to IMAX  wow it must be one of those big giant  movies and so what we've done is we've  created this new tradition that allows  people to recognize when they're going  to come to an IMAX movie they're gonna  see an event we do that primarily on  three key components the picture and  size of the sound picture mean  crystal-clear images size meaning  streams up to eight stories tall and  sound twelve thousand watts of digital  surround sound  you're able to have an opinion  experience that gets everyone pumped and  excited about it you actually feel like  you're it's an image the quality it's  just so much more crisp the sound that  you can feel the sound it's the best  cinema it exists